don't want to lose him
you have to let me go let me dye your
hair now that last scene between Killian
and Emma was really a blow to the
stomach literally and she's now
hell-bent on going to the underworld so
that she can share a heart with her man
and save him at what lengths is she
willing to go I mean I think there's no
limits to where she's willing to go at
this point she's gone through so much to
get to a place in her life where she is
strong enough and vulnerable enough to
love without walls up and she's
determined to save hook and obviously
desperate to save hook because it's the
stakes are very high at this point he's
actually in the underworld she's not a
great situation he genuinely sacrificed
himself for the greater good and tried
to make a difference in the world he
tried to redeem himself and you know
that's where he is but he's suffering in
the underworld he's suffering really
badly we've been talking about how much
the fans love the relationship between
Killian and Emma what is it about this
couple that's so special I think because
it's hard work for them and I mean that
that sends I don't mean that send a bad
way I know it's fantastical because
obviously he's Captain Hook and she's
the daughter of you know Snow White and
Prince Charming but it's in a weird way
it's kind of real yeah and I think
that's why people respond to because
it's not easy it's not just oh look at
them they're in love
fantastic it's hard and they work at it
and they love each other so that's the
way it is I think she'd rather die than
not be with him like please don't let it
come to that I'm not the writers I
didn't I didn't write that I'm just
saying I think then from her perspective
I think that she feels like you know her
the best version of her life will be
with him
I will always
now when we last saw Emma she uttered
those famous words that her parents
always say I will always find you
it's the Charmy motto exactly so why do
you think that snow and charming are the
ultimate relationship goals why are they
the ultimate relationship goals it's
true love it is true love pure and
simple
so you can't get better than that